good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
the united states remains the most
powerful country in the world that's the
good news what's interesting
is that this country has occupied that
position for so long
that relatively few americans have
considered what would happen if we
slipped from that perch
would it matter if america became
subordinate to other nations
there's a debate about that let's see at
work does it matter to you who the boss
is
it probably does matter that's the
person who can fire you
and the world isn't so different from
that the top countries give the orders
the rest of the planet takes the orders
whether they like it or not
we've lost sight of that because for
more than a century america
effectively has been in charge of much
of the world and that's exactly why we
have stayed rich
and free for that time most americans on
some level
understand that this is an arrangement
worth preserving if only because the
options to it are so much worse
how'd you like to be forced to obey the
chinese communist party
not so much how would you feel about
surrendering the us
dollar as the world's reserve currency
and immediately going bankrupt
no thanks most of us would like to avoid
outcomes like that and that's why we
spend more than any country in the world
on our military
there's a reason the department of
defense is our largest government agency
it's not just because defense
contractors are powerful
it's because we all agree it's really
important in exchange for all that money
and all that power and all the little
oversight we give it
we expect in return the pentagon will
stay up late thinking of ways to keep
america strong the question is have they
been doing that
when you can judge for yourself most of
the generals we see quoted in the press
seem more committed to meeting some
counterproductive diversity goal
hiring more pregnant air force pilots
assembling the world's first transgender
seal team
than on defending the united states the
conflicts the pentagon says it's
preparing for
often seem comically small and outdated
almost from colonial times whether it's
wrangling with illiterate tribesmen in
afghanistan that's very important
or ramping up for some new war against a
remote group of buildings in syria where
the hell
syria is can poor irrelevant countries
really be
our gravest enemies we act like it but
they're not
and that's been confirmed tonight by the
way this nation's most
forbiddable foe the new defense
secretary just told us
is the weather itself going forward the
u.s military has declared a hot war on
global warming
today no nation can find lasting
security without addressing
the climate crisis we face all kinds of
threats in our line of work but
few of them truly deserve to be called
existential
a climate crisis does deserve to be
called
existential existential
if you've got a cliche he will read it
on television lloyd austin of course
lloyd austin is a former defense
contractor not surprisingly he's a
full-time audio log as well
having lloyd austin at the pentagon is
like handing control of the entire us
military to the editorial page of the
new york times here is lloyd austin
explaining that the single scariest
risk our soldiers face is the
possibility they might have to serve
alongside americans who didn't vote for
joe biden
and if confirmed i will fight hard to
stamp out sexual assault
and to rid our ranks of racist and
extremists
the job of the department of defense is
to keep america safe from our enemies
but we can't do that if some of those
enemies lie within our own ranks
he's a joke and a mediocrity and of
course he was confirmed
by the senate as if he was impressive
but he's not and the results are
entirely predictable a new report in
revolver news puts a finer point on what
exactly is happening at the pentagon
under lloyd austin
austin has hired an activist type called
bishop garrison as the head of the
military's vast
diversity and inclusion apparatus a
group of offices that has nothing to do
with fighting and winning wars
just spend five minutes googling bishop
garrison treats yourself he's a lunatic
a few years ago he announced that anyone
who supports donald trump that would be
tens of millions of american citizens
many of whom have served in the military
is a white supremacist and by the way he
said there is no room for nuance quote
on that question
garrison wrote a lot of things like that
again like that you can google it again
you should
now and this is the point he's one of
the most powerful officials in the us
military
democrats in congress are thrilled as
they watch this their party now has
all the tanks and drones what's strange
is that republicans don't seem to have
noticed that it happened
they're still giving the same vacuous
speeches about the troops
and then of course signing off on ever
expanding defense budgets
with no oversight the effect the same
fighting force that for generations we
have been so proud of
the people who stormed saipan and
guadalcanal have been captured without a
shot by people who seem like rejects
from the google hr department
and its defenders the defenders of the
troops can't be bothered to say a word
about it do they have television
have they seen the army's latest
recruiting ad
this is the story of a soldier who
operates your nation's patriot missile
defense
systems
it begins in california with a little
girl
raised by two moms although i had a
fairly typical childhood
took ballet played violin
i also marched for equality i like to
think i've been defending freedom from
an early age
a way to prove my inner strength and
maybe shatter some stereotypes
along the way i also march for equality
oh shut up who cares please stop talking
about yourself
for once it is boring and irrelevant and
insulting this is not
just your country it belongs to all of
us your job is to defend it please do so
yet it's becoming clear they have no
interest in defending it and here's the
latest evidence of that it comes from
cbs last night
this is a clip from a 60 minutes report
on of all things
ufos and the u.s military watch this
[Music]
a navy air crew struggles to lock onto a
fast-moving object
off the u.s atlantic coast in 2015.
[Applause]
recently released images may not
convince ufo skeptics but the pentagon
admits
it doesn't know what in the world this
is
or this or this
oh ufos they're spooky and kind of funny
crazy people believe in them up until
you get to the line
the pentagon admits it doesn't know what
in the world this is
and that's where you pause because from
a national security perspective
that is a very big problem how big a
problem is it
one navy pilot said that the u.s
military has observed
unidentified flying objects maneuvering
in restricted airspace
off the coast of virginia quote every
day
for two years the pentagon confirms
these are images of objects it can't
identify
lieutenant graves told us pilots
training off the atlantic coast
see things like that all the time
every day every day for at least a
couple years
wait a minute every day for a couple of
years
every day for gears now flying in
restricted airspace
is not a small thing try that in your
cessna 172 off virginia beach sometime
you will get very wet very fast you'll
be killed actually
yet the pentagon after every day for
two years of daily incursions didn't
appear to do anything about it why
didn't they
we're just guessing one possible
explanation they couldn't
our military was completely outmatched
technologically by whatever these were
and whatever they were
they were not weather balloons here's
lou elizondo the former director of the
advanced aerospace threat identification
program
you know how this sounds it sounds nutty
wacky
look bill i'm not i'm not telling you
that that it doesn't sound wacky what
i'm telling you it's real
imagine a technology that can do six to
seven hundred g forces
that can fly at 13 000 miles an hour
that
it can evade radar and that can fly
through
air and water and possibly space
and oh by the way has no obvious signs
of propulsion no
wings no control surfaces and yet still
can defy the natural effects of earth's
gravity
that's precisely what we're seeing
sound like a potential threat you think
so what is the pentagon
done about it well we don't know the
full story as of tonight but we don't
know they've done
anything about it other than ignore it
and then
cover the fact they ignored it by
declaring the whole subject classified
for decades and then spending the rest
of the day thinking about how to bomb
syria again
and rid the marine corps of people who
voted for donald trump
the sad thing is we have a whole new
branch of the military that might be
perfectly designed to assess what these
things are
and figure out if they're a threat or
not maybe respond if there was ever a
reason to have space
force this might be it but space forces
otherwise occupied these days they're
busy conducting political purges of
their own
ranks as all the branches the military
are here's lieutenant colonel
matthew lohmeir he commanded a space
force unit until the white house decided
that his politics were not acceptable
since taking command as a commander
about 10 months ago
i saw what i consider fundamentally
incompatible and competing narratives of
what america was
is and should be that wasn't just
prolific and social media
or spreading throughout the country uh
during this past year but it was uh
spreading throughout the united states
military and i had recognized uh those
narratives
as being marxist in nature
so every day for two years unidentified
flying
objects behaving in ways that seem to
contradict what we know about
physics and the us military is spending
its time as of right now
purging its strengths what does this
remind you maybe the soviet army 1938
a clear and present threat appears on
the horizon but people in charge
are so obsessed with political purity
and loyalty to the party that they can't
respond because they're absorbed in
attacking their own organization
when they say that all revolutions are
the same they're right
ufos it turns out are real and whatever
else they are
they are a prima facie challenge to the
u.s military
they are doing things the u.s military
does not allow and they're doing it with
impunity
and they appear to be focused on the us
military ufos for decades appear to have
clustered around our military
installations our ships and our aircraft
with no real response except more
secrecy
at one point unidentified flying objects
apparently shut down a nuclear weapons
facility at an air force base in the
state of montana
10 icbms inter
ballistic missiles intercontinentalistic
missiles were temporarily knocked
offline
at the same time base security noticed a
glowing red object floating in the sky
it sounds like out of a movie but it
happened
that was decades ago many more ufos have
been cited near our nuclear weapons
facilities since around the country
according to journalist george knapp
quote all of the nuclear facilities los
alamos livermore
sandias savannah hill all had dramatic
incidents with these unknown aircraft
appearing over the facilities and no one
knew where they were from
or what they were doing there again for
decades
this has happened apparently no one
knows why no one seems especially
alarmed
in the 1950s some people were worried
about this the classified fbi document
from 70 years ago describes unknown
flying objects measuring
50 feet in diameter in the vicinity of
los alamos
more recently the pentagon is
declassified footage from the u.s ufo
incident in 2004
and two ufo incidents from 2015 you're
seeing that footage
it was recorded by navy pilots during
training flights
we have no explanation for what these
objects are just days ago the pentagon
confirmed that an 18-second video of
three ufos
harassing a u.s warship called the uss
russell
is in fact real that footage was shot in
july of 2019
and collected by the ufo's u of
pentagon's ufo task force
then went up in the hands of jeremy
corbell the journalist who put it online
so the question is what are these things
why are they buzzing our skies why do
they seem attracted to the united states
military and why above all
isn't the pentagon more focused on this
it seems like a threat if there ever was
one
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else